Malik wants Ma. Ma, don't talk to me,
man. Get out my face, Ma. You're fake.
Get your fake stuff off my face, bro.
Get out my face. M, can you step away
from me, please? You see how they're
following? He's following me. So, if I
feel like I got to defend myself after
moving around, that's what it is.
>> No, we've known you for a little bit.
Question. Muslims have a little bit of
question, right?
>> Muslims are you?
>> The Muslims. The Muslims. The Muslim
community. The Muslim community on
TikTok. The Muslim DA community, right?
Because you know, you you you come into
San Diego and then, you know, we usually
have a conversation. It's respectful. So
we saw you on a live recently or on a
you know on YouTube recently sitting
with David Wood. David Wood has ripped
up the Quran. He eats the Quran. So our
question is do you condemn David Wood
for that action of ripping the Quran and
eating it? Do you condemn him?
>> Not in that context.
>> What do you mean?
>> So uh the stance that I have is is that
if somebody is provoked then you cannot
complain or cry at their reaction.
Right? And so let me tell you the
content of this. I'm not asking about
the provoking. I'm asking about taking
it I'm No, no. I'm asking I'm asking
about anybody that gets provoked in any
manner. A Muslim could get provoked. And
if a Muslim does that, we as Muslims
would condemn a Muslim regardless for
ripping not all of you. Allow us to
respond. Respond. For ripping up the
Bible, a book that is held respectfully
by by people of Christianity. If he were
to do that, we Muslims would condemn
him. So, we thought that, you know,
since you're friendly with us, you're
friendly with some Muslims.
But you're sitt
just just a few days ago
>> um there was a guy his name is Henny on
YouTube you know or TikTok you know him
>> I've heard of him. Yeah. Yeah.
>> So I was on a I was on a Muslim I was on
Muslim uh cousins live and he came up
and he ripped the took the Bible and he
ripped the page out of the Bible.
>> Yeah. Now the Muslims in the comment
section were saying yes yes
alhamdulillah yeah and then they
actually condemn cuz Muslim cousin the
host he's a Muslim he actually kicked
him for doing that right all right watch
this watch this but the other Muslims in
the chat they were getting a Muslim
cousin and talk fearing him for saying
that he's siding with the Christians for
condemning the Muslim for doing that
>> so my point is is that I know that you
and people like Omar stuff like you guys
will condemn something like that people
like Muslim cousin he'll condemn it then
but there's also the other side of
Muslims that celebrate asking about the
Muslim right no I know I'm asking about
you no but what you do let me finish but
you got let me finish but you're going
to Muslims but I'm asking about
Christian but notice you got to listen
to why I did this because you would No
it's brother I'm asking you about Ma let
me tell you why
>> okay I'll respond to you
>> because you brought up Muslim actions I
didn't you said Muslims would condemn
this Muslims would do this Muslims would
do that Muslims. Let me finish. Have
Muslims a Muslim cousin did, but Muslims
also advocated for it.
>> Okay, that's fine.
Let me say this. Yeah. Let me finish,
bro.
>> All right. Go ahead.
>> So, my point is is that you can't say we
as Muslims would condemn this because
you as Muslims wouldn't, some of you
would, some of you would not. Some of
you celebrate it. Some of you be like,
"Nah, that that ain't cool." Right? So,
this is the spectrum that we have. Now,
when you Let me finish cuz you're asking
me on why I held the position I had. a
long answer, bro.
>> I know it is, but it's it's deep. So,
when some when somebody says, "Oh, if
you don't want an answer, then shut up
and get out my face." You know what I'm
saying? So,
>> is this the Christian love?
>> Yeah, this is the Christian love. Yeah,
this is the Christian love. Let me go
ahead.
>> All right. So, now when you ask me why
what why my position is is because you
got the Muslims. He's responding to
Muslims. You talking to me? You listen?
>> Yeah. Go ahead. Go ahead. Talk to He's
so he's responding to Muslims who are
posting pictures of my wife, posting
pictures of other Christians wives,
posting pictures of his wife. I got to
jump in. What do you have to jump in
for?
>> Okay, I got to jump in because
>> in terms of him being provoked, you can
have a position on that. Okay. Would you
say a Muslim cousin's a good Muslim?
>> Uh, no.
>> Muslim cousin is not a good man.
>> I a good man. Sure. Do you praise Do you
praise him for what he [laughter]
>> do? Do you praise him for what he did
when he dropped uh hanging off the bus?
>> Absolutely.
>> Okay. Not as a Muslim, as a man.
>> Are there bad Christians and good
Christians out there or is that
Christian? Okay, cool. So So would you
say that if if if when David Wood does
action like as a good Christian,
shouldn't you condemn that?
>> No.
>> Okay, perfect. So what about Okay, cool.
What about when his panel, went on his
live, and he did it without being
provoked? David Wood ripped the Quran,
ate it without anyone provoking him just
because he felt like doing it. Would you
uh condemn that?
>> Well, actually, he was insulting, but
let me But but let me but yeah, let me
let me answer you. No, cuz cuz you cuz
you muddied the water.
>> Not really, though. Because you did. No,
but but I'm helping you out. Notice how
you're cutting me off my answer, bro.
You're not allowing me to speak. Bro,
you don't want to go oneonone. You're
not allowing me to go.
Focus. Bro, focus.
>> Okay. If you don't want to, if you don't
want to engage,
look, but he's jumping in, bro. If you
don't want to [laughter]
talk about the trinity focus,
>> you have to let me finish what I'm
saying in terms of it's not about him
being provoked.
>> If you do this, I'm going to have to
talk over you. We're going to talk.
>> We're going to talk over each other
then, bro. Then we're not going to have
this conversation. Successful
conversation.
>> You're right. So, I'm telling you, David
Wood has done it without being provoked.
>> Oh, I didn't. You got to show me that.
>> Because [laughter]
Anas was insulting. Anas was insulting.
>> Okay. So, so he was provoked. Even if a
Christian when I when I say notice how
you're talking over me again because
so if it goes unprovoked I condemn that.
>> Okay.
>> If he's provoked
>> hey
if it's free game right now so if
there's some brother he did it he did it
unprovoked.
>> No he did it after you guys did it.
>> So no here it is. He came on the
platform unprovoked and ripped a Bible.
Now guess now guess what? Because of
what David and David Wood did. because
of what and what what Malik and and the
others are doing. He's the one that
start. So notice so no what he started
who started it. David was starting the
trend. No see and this is the and this
is the problem with Muslims. They won't
go to their to their origin. They'll
look at the Muslim reaction but they
won't go with the Muslim. I don't want
to hear the cry around us. I don't want
to cry when he's in San Die.
You don't want to [laughter]
condemn me. You don't want to condemn
me.
David,
the Bible, you don't want to condemn it
TO
JESUS. SO, I'm done with that. I'm doing
all that.
>> Jesus submit to Allah.
But let's get No, you're not. You're
not. I'm going do it, too. You're in
You're in your emotions. You know my
personality. Me and you are cool. But
you got to answer. But you got to be
>> and [laughter] I did answer. And I'm
telling you if Henny did that provoked
or not provoked Islamically prohibited.
You're telling me as Okay, I'm talking
to bro. You're telling me as a Christian
provoked or not provoked, it's okay if
he's provoked. Even if he's not
provoked, I'm going TO MAKE AN EXCUSE
BECAUSE HE GOT INSULTED.
>> So notice what [laughter] he got in
So notice how I just heard you out.
Notice I just did I just hear you?
>> You've cut me off right now.
>> No, I just I just let you talk, bro. I
let you get it off. kind of spoke before
I finished though. But go ahead.
>> Okay. So, you just misrepresented what I
said. I did not say you said that
self control.
Say with ME
>> Allahbar Allahbar.
Trust me, we Muslims could be louder. I
promise you. Okay. [laughter]
face.
The whole issue if so if the Muslim
provokes the Christian by putting up
people's wives. Hold on, don't answer by
putting up people's wives.
>> By putting pictures of people's wives by
putting pictures on people's wives. Do
you do you do you disagree with the
wives? Do you disagree? He raped the
minor. Do you disagree? He raped her. Do
you disagree
limit passing stat of limitation?
[laughter] Oh, no. They did this to me
before.
>> This was This is after. Yeah. But to me
IT WAS BEFORE.
>> To me it was before.
>> David
Wood is a pedophile.
[laughter]
>> Wood is a pedophile. What is that? David
Wood is a pedophile. [laughter]
>> Muhammad is a pedophile. I agree.
brother. Step
agree with you. This guy don't want to
talk about the trinity.
This guy's loud.
>> We totally agree with you. This guy's
loud as a pedophile.
All right.
We agree with you. All right. All right.
All right. All right. [screaming] All
right. All right. So, we got emotional.
We got chill, bro. Chill.
You going to talk about a Christian? I'M
TALKING ABOUT DIFFERENT look how
sensitive you're a hypocrite, [laughter]
bro. Stop being a hypocrite. And
Muhammad said that he slept with Aisha
when she was nine. So if he's bringing
that up, you can't hide that.
>> David Wood confessed to raping a minor.
He confessed ON VIDEO. WHY YOU MAD at
me? Nobody's mad at you. But if you're
going to if you're going to condemn
David Wood, then condemn Muhammad.
[laughter] Don't condemn Muhammad.
>> The prophet Muhammad never raped anyone.
David's a rapist.
So you're not going to hold on. So
you're not going to condemn him for in
the Bible.
He's a liar. He's a liar. You just lied.
You saidam
said that he slept with Aisha when she
was nine.
>> Yeah. I misspoke. I said I mean I SAID
[screaming]
[laughter] I said is it a lie? Is it
true?
IS IT IS IT TRUE? It's time to pray.
>> Is it true?
>> So you want to talk about the prophet on
the prophet?
>> Is it true?
>> The truth.
>> Who said lying on the prophet? Is it
true? Say what you said about the
mother. Say what you said. Say what you
said.
[laughter]
Hold on. Look. We're going to do it like
this.
The prophet Muhammad. I could just
repeat what the Muslims are saying about
your wife.
>> Would you?
>> I'm asking you. Would you? Are you going
to condemn her?
>> No. You're not going to condemn her. And
I don't condemn who's speaking about
your wife. I don't condemn that. Let me
go promote that. [laughter]
Come on, brother.
No. I'm not I'm not emotional about you,
bro. I'm not emotional.
>> As the father of a little girl, huh? The
father of a little girl. We believe
Jesus [laughter] apostle will return. We
believe he will rule the earth as a
righteous king on earth. Muslim king
following Islam following Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. Me as a
Muslim I have no problem signing a
contract when my daughter is of age. I
want her to be the husband of
the prophet [laughter] of Allah
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. Even if she
was like six or five,
>> if she was six and five, I would sign a
contract when she is of age because when
she is of age of sound mind, body,
understanding, physical, don't cover her
mouth. Don't cover Hey, brother.
Brother, just really quick, Mich.
Yeah. I'm going to need you to step away
from my wife, please. No, no, no. Out of
respect, stay step away from my wife.
Don't step She's Okay, [laughter]
brother. I I don't want to get physical.
I don't want to get physical. Please
step for my wife. Don't step for my
wife. Please step for my wife.
[laughter] Yeah. Please step for my
wife. Don't step on my wife. Step for my
wife. He didn't step for my wife. You
step for my wife. No, I did that. He's
too close. He's too close. He didn't
touch her. He's going to bring her. He's
going to have to be moved. He didn't
bring her.
>> He's going to have to be moved. He
touched me. Simple as that. I sure did.
>> I sure did. Come over here, brother.
>> So, you arrest my wife, you will be
touched,
>> homie.
>> Anyway,
>> you'll be moved straight up. He didn't
touch your wife. He went to he shoulder
to shoulder with my wife covering my
cover. He was putting he will not be
your brother.
>> He was a camera.
>> Check him. Check him. Check your brother
or else I will check him. Simple as
that. Every single person
single female.
>> So I'm good. So I'm going to hold my
brothers in check. Hold your brothers in
check. You did not hold him in check.
>> Oh yeah, I did. No, you didn't. You
didn't.
>> You said you don't kill them. What you
said?
[laughter] Did you cut it out? Cut it
out. Chill out. No, I'm I'mma give it to
You going to be cool, bro. You going to
be cool.
>> You going to be cool?
>> Okay. No, if you're not going to be
cool, hold on. Just really quick. Really
quick,
>> you need to chill, bro. You need It's
his phone. It's his phone. I'm give it
to him. Okay.
>> Recorded. Who recorded us? Who recorded?
>> Let me Let me
>> Yeah. Deal with him, bro.
Get him away from my wife, bro.
Someone called the
>> Yeah. If you guys got a prank, go for
So the point of the matter is, right, I
have no problem signing a contract of
premarriage to give my wife to Jesus,
peace be upon him because I know he's
Jesus. when the time comes, if I see
him, if we're alive at that time, and
all of the signs of there, him killing
the antichrist, him doing what he's
doing, be given that sovereign the the
sovereign rule from Allah on earth,
meaning that he's going to rule the only
ruler as a Muslim on earth following
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam's
religion and way of Allah subhana wa
tala that was sent to him. I have no
problem signing my dra even in the womb.
as a Muslim
what about consummation
>> in Islam the consummation isn't set at a
exact date I know isn't sex at an age if
she was
>> you said you know but you did not give
them what he
>> if she was nine because if she was nine
would you let would you let him
consummate
>> when people used to live at that time
when people used to live at
>> I just want to know if you at nine would
you let your daughter consummate with a
grown man if she's married
>> if the time was different and she had
sound mind and that don't have the
maturity to get married there's
40-year-olds that you look at them, they
have the mind of a 10-year-old, men and
women. So, this is not Islam to say that
there's a set age of marriage and
herself mentioned that which her herself
did not even celebrate birthdays. They
don't do what they do like they do have
a thing.
>> Would you let your 9-year-old signed
over to Would you let her?
>> I would let my daughter signed off to
>> Would you let her would you let him if
that is what the time at that time?
>> No, I'm talking your time. If if nine
years
>> if he if he cracked the sky right now
>> if 9 years from now there is all of
those calamities wars and whatever and
my daughter reached that age or after
>> she's nine she's 9 years old
>> after if I was living at that time the
brother listen to my question if Isa
hold on if Issa bin Mariam crack the sky
right now
>> right to come rule and he said I want
your daughter would you give him your
daughter
>> I I would rush to be that And would you
let him consummate
>> to let he would be the one understanding
the rules of Allahh
>> if he wanted to consummate right with
with your daughter at
harmful to her because it would not be
that which Allah
because Allah is the one that you know
if it's harmful
is the one that set those commandments.
So he would follow Allah never set those
commandments. The commandment of being
of sound mind body
>> that's not in the Quran. It is in the
hadith and Allah says it's not in the
hadith either.
>> There's no nothing said there's nothing
in the hadith that says that you have to
be of sound mind and mature body in
order to in order to
you don't need to you have to call them.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Let's get going cuz it's already
time. Quick real quick. You said the
Quran said 4 that the the horse of the
girls let me finish. Show him before
before they show premarital.
It said it says they have that the the
yes the the contra
>> according to the means that you're
touched
>> no not necessarily
>> chapter 33:49 that you don't have an
unless you touch right now the what what
is the
>> it's a waiting period the waiting period
is there right because I can remarry
that person in the period
>> yeah so this is Islam
>> according to 3349 they don't have
you would say now this is this is how
dumb the argument is do they have an
all of the girls of the people got
All of the the
>> David Wood unprovoked.
>> Did they Did they have did they look if
you have an
>> Do you have an If you didn't have sex
>> no one provoked No one provoked David
Wood in both your videos.
>> Do they have a hidden if they didn't
have sex? So right now because he comes
to us and he he acts friendly with us.
>> He condemns the action of one.
>> One of the things it's not just about
seeing the marriage action. You're still
we just want to know if it was someone
according to what you're saying
[laughter] was unprovoked. They would
not unprovoke.
So the point
[laughter]
is for me to take the wife
and to make sure she's not pregnant,
right?
All of the guardians, all of the
guardians are
they would have to have some sort of
according to what you believe provoke us
weakness of the mind to give their
children at a young age. I agree. So you
think that's disgusting. So like but
you're understand
right now like I said this is this is
this is this is universal
of Allah is disgusting. I don't believe
that Jesus when he returns he will be
disgusting. I don't believe he will rule
with other than that which Allah
>> Yeah. But this is what I'm saying in in
the Quran it allows you to have
relationship. We got a girl
to sign a contract [laughter] even I got
you. But in chapter 33:49,
they don't look in chapter 3:49, it says
that they don't have an if they haven't
been touched.
>> You don't have an unless you've been
touched.
>> That's what the Quran says verbatim.
>> So right now, you're taking a Quran
verse without understanding the
tied to
>> what do I need to understand of that if
the Quran is verbatim? Because Allah
says that there are some verses that are
Allah told you to fast.
>> What does mean the
there clear and concise is this verse
clear?
>> Allah says pray. Allah says marry. Allah
says divorce. Allah says do this do
that. But then when when the verse says
hold on when the when the verse says
when the verse says if you have
believing women and divorce them before
you have touched them they do not have
an Is that clear?
>> You're just reading. Show them.
>> I know. I'm just reading.
>> That's that's the thing about it. I'm
just reading the verse.
>> You're just saying you're not reading.
>> No, that's verbatim what the verse says.
You want me to show it?
>> So right now right now I'll show you.
Like I mentioned the hadith is there to
explain the Quran and everything in the
Quran Allah says pray right and Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam explains to
us how to pray so there is one and one
they come together I don't take the
words of Allah and derive my own meaning
or take the words of someone who might
have a sick intention
>> right I know you have separation in some
manner of your way of life and
Christianity to agree.
>> You do or you don't.
>> No, you don't see different things than
in reality that you're living your way
of life.
>> No, my my African American slash your
your slash your Christian.
>> I see my my entire life is me through
the lens of Christianity
>> and you derive everything from your own
opinion from what you see in the world.
>> No, not no but from what Jesus said.
>> Your way from your way.
>> No, from what it says. Your way of
understand.
>> No, from what it says. So Islam came as
a mercy to mankind with the explanation
from that who was sent as a mercy to
mankind. I'm not going to sit with you
right now when I have a few minutes left
to go out right and explain to you the
judicial rulings
marital relations. I explained
there are people that they get married.
I can write a marriage contract and I
can take it off. There are people
written to get married
before she married.
She was written to marry one of the she
was written to marry someone else
before.
Why is it horrible? She used to do that
to marry the truth.
>> Okay. And then but I got you. But the
actual marriaging and then the
consummation
>> when the person when the person
themselves wants I want you to in
America today [laughter]
I don't care about that. talk to you
about today.
>> I only care about I only care about
objectivity not cultural relativity
is our mother. She is one of the
narrators of hadith. She has someone
that is a scholar. The the companions
took knowledge from her. She was too
young woman within the bash and and
>> she was still playing with dolls
brother. Manners of Islam.
>> Yeah. with the said she was still
playing with dolls when when Muhammad
said I want you to repeat what you said
to me earlier she left playing with
dolls
>> no she was in
do you want me to show you the
>> she herself said that you're talking
about herself
>> no she herself said she still had dolls
with her
[laughter]
she said she was playing when Muhammad
>> the companions the companions
Praise him. Stay quiet. Follow a good
boy. Just be a good doggy. If I don't
just be a good dog.
>> Come on, bro. Let's Let's keep it
respectful, man. Come on, guys.
>> I mean, he he's trying to insult my
prophet Avery and you're not
>> Yeah, but you you No, you brought the
energy insulting a Christian and Dave
and all this kind of stuff. When you
bring this energy, you're going to get
this. So, chill. Everybody needs to
chill.
>> So, he hears you. Tell him not to come,
dog. That's going to be burned.
>> He hears you, bro. He hears you.
>> All I hear is a rat. Huh? All I hear is
a rat talking.
I don't care who it is.
>> Do you want to see the verse? [laughter]
>> I know that she was playing with dogs.
>> You know full well the hadith. You know
full well what
said.
>> Yeah. She said, "And I used to play with
dolls." I told you. You had this
exertion upon the guy putting a camera
in front of your wife.
>> Correct.
>> What does that to do with I used to play
with dolls? because she is our mother
and you us defending her honor and honor
of Allah is greater than that which you
have.
>> So we got we got your wife
that said the prophet but yeah but we
both as important the only thing
restraining me in talking to you in a
manner that I know that you are speaking
from a place of ignorance is my belief
and my Islam.
>> Wait, what is ignorant about what I'm
saying?
>> Look look I'm I'm not I'm not being
disrespectful, right? We're just talking
about the sources. You did not even that
guy called our our prophet a very bad
word. He did right and he said you
condemn him. He said you do not.
>> Yeah. So this is something that you
>> What does that have to what does that
do? Do you agree with that? I I based on
the definition I agree.
>> Okay then we can have a conversation.
Why? Best because this is something
disrespectful.
No brother
you asked me my view and it's based on
the sources. I don't know what other
Muslims as an insult
>> or other people said about your wife,
what they did. I don't have time to sit
there and watch videos, but I would
never dishonor your family. I would
never even put her in a bad state. I
would even put someone in their place.
Why? Why? Because of Islam. Because of
and all of Islam all of that which she
came with. by the way.
>> But notice this. All of the all of the
wives of the prophet were commandments
from Allah to be married. I agree with
you.
>> And they were commandments. But here's
my point.
What was going on?
>> If I'm reading a source, right? If I'm
reading If I'm reading a source, look
listen. If I'm bringing a critique
against Muhammad, right? I'm not coming.
Look, notice how I haven't cursed at
you. I haven't You're right. I haven't
spoken.
Listen to what I'm saying. If you have a
definition, if there's a definition,
right? of an action of pedophilia for
example, right? Is that something? Let's
let's do something less like you know
let's say murder for example, right? If
we're talking having affections for for
minors and young people
>> having affections for minors [laughter]
and young people that's usually someone
who has affection for young people to
have marriages with people that were
>> Yeah, that's that's and you would agree
that that's disgusting today to have
sexual relations.
>> I think universally it's not okay.
Universally it doesn't matter about
today. It does matter. It does matter.
So in one point it's okay to sleep with
minors and in you call a minor. What is
the 17 year olds? They are what
[laughter] get married?
>> Thank you so much.
>> In California if two 17y olds get
married in California. What about a 17y
old California a 30-year-old can marry a
16-year-old if the parents of the old in
California?
>> You'd have to I don't care about that.
>> There is no set age in California.
>> So why why are you point Why are you
pointing to the incident? ex exists. You
call him that. We don't call. [laughter]
Yeah, you do. Are they Are they
not the infidel is someone who had that
infidelity? It has to do with marriage
separation from the Let's use a
different word Christian.
>> Why are you using Why are you pointing
Why are you using the taffer to help to
help to help supplement your defense of
Muhammad and
>> showing the hypocrisy? This is the
reality. Look, I'm saying if if somebody
signs their 16-year-old daughter to
marriage, I'm saying that they shouldn't
do that. If someone is 16 of sound age,
mind and body, and they have a need to
get married and they want to get
married, they should get married and the
guardian should make sure that person
that she's marrying is good for her, not
going to use her, not going to abuse
her, can take care of her, not going to
if she's if she's a little girl and he's
a grown adult and he's using her
sexually, that's abuse.
>> That's not abuse because abuse would
take someone
At that time it was not because that
9year-old is in front of the
40-year-old.
>> This is a touchy subject even if she
exactly I got you. Let's drop the
subject on the live.
>> No, this this just a touch.
Like I said, I have no problem signing
my daughter. Please, please, let's drop
it.
>> Let's drop him. M.
>> We got to drop the subject. I love him
more than you love him.
>> Oh, no you don't. You don't know him.
You don't know. You had a daughter.
Would you rush today? No. You know, and
and Jesus and Jesus who is holy and
righteous would never ask for my little
girl. He will never cuz he's better.
He's holy. He's pure. He would never he
would never ask for a little girl.
>> He admitted it. He admitted it.
>> We need to pray.
>> But thank you for the conversation. This
was good. This was a good conversation,
right? It got tougher. Got tough at the
end with the study subject, but this was
a good conversation.
>> Clarification to the guy that you took
his phone and threw it to the
>> See, Michelle, my respect. I'm not I
don't want to talk to you if you're
gonna keep doing that. If you're gonna
do that, you lost my respect.
>> What did I do?
>> You lie and say that I provoked it. So,
was he was he not too close? He got too
close. He did what he did over there.
>> So, he provoked it. Correct.
>> Yes.
>> Answer the question, Michelle.
>> He was there. See how this guy is? How?
>> No. No. No. That's not where he was. He
was right here. That's where he was.
>> You pushed him. You pushed him to your
wife.
>> Get out. Get out. Get Get out of here,
bro. You push this guy. Michelle, I
can't I can't respect you right now if
you're going to do this guy to your
wife.
>> I can't respect you right now if you're
going to do this. I understand you. I
can't respect you. You can get I can't I
can't respect this
>> and protect your wife. That is
commendable.
>> I can't respect this.
>> But you can't when you lie and your
Muslim brother your Muslim brother
provokes an action and you can't even be
honest about that. There's nothing for
us to say.
>> Now you call him my Muslim brother.
>> Yeah, that's your Muslim brother.
>> You said he's a Shia.
>> Is he your Muslim brother?
>> You just said earlier
>> and you and he said he said he was.
>> So you're using
>> He said he was using a double stand.
>> He said he was your Muslim brother. You
want to, you have it.
>> He said he was your Muslim brother. I'm
going off what he said.
>> Don't I'm going off what he said.
>> Don't call. I'll take your statement.
>> I'm going off of what he said. He said
that you guys are Muslim brothers.
>> That's what he said.
>> You said the religion teaches
>> Yeah. That's what the religion teaches.
Muhammad said if you see Muhammad said
if you see
if you see a Jew or Christian Muhammad
said if you see a Jew or Christian do
not initiate the salam the peace
greeting but instead force them to the
narrower side. Is that hate or is that
love?
>> So Allah subhana wa tala I didn't say no
there's a difference. You love your
wife. You're not going to love some
random woman like you love.
>> Is that hate or love? I'm not I'm not
going to force I'm not going to force a
woman that's not my wife to the
narrowest road. Is that hate or love?
Allah subhana wa ta'ala mentions those
>> I just want to know if it's hate or love
>> that attack you and have anger towards
you enmity towards you and Allah says in
the Quran that he does not leave you
away from those that are kind to be kind
to them and just to
>> then why does Muhammad say not to be
kind to the Jew and Christian initially
>> it's not about being kind do not
initiate that with what who
>> the peace the Jews and the Christians he
says
>> because they're the Jews and the
Christians
>> what were they doing at the time they
disbelieved That's what they did. They
disbelieved.
>> Did not fight against the prophet.
>> The Christians, didn't he? What
Christian? What? What Christian war
against Muhammad?
>> The That's what Tabuk was about. What?
>> What? What? Yeah. What was that about?
>> What was it? You
>> You don't know. [laughter]
>> That's what you were asking was about
the the Christians getting armed and
ready to go attack.
>> Why? Why?
>> Why?
>> Because Muhammad wrote a letter to the
leader and said, "Convert or we're going
to come for your things."
>> Is that what he said?
>> Yep. Is that the
>> that's what that's what that's what it
letter is still there is that people can
follow it and check it online you guys
can check it this is a testament that
letter huh to Heraculus is a testament
to the truth
>> so you do know it so okay so according
I'm saying so so they were getting ready
to defend themselves against Muhammad
right
>> do not do not claim that something is in
>> why no answer
>> when it is not in the religion
>> were they getting ready to defend
themselves against Muhammad
>> Allah subhanana wa ta'ala came with
truth and falsehood, you know, because
you've had multitudes of conversations
with us and Muhammad and other brothers
off of camera and you agree.
>> You agree
>> with what?
>> A lot of stuff.
>> With what?
>> With like what?
>> Nothing. I don't agree with none of you.
You your your theology. Nothing.
>> No, there's nothing that we agree on.
>> You have no problem with
>> I have a problem with Yes.
>> before you had no problem with
>> I always have a problem with
>> you. You didn't say you have no problem
with
>> I always have a problem with bro.
>> All right. Have a nice night.
>> You too, man. Jeez, Mashia. Come on,
man.
>> Malik wants M. Ma, don't talk to me,
man. Get out of my face. M. You're fake.
Get your fake stuff off my face, bro.
>> Want to talk to you.
>> Get out my face, man.
>> Get away from me, M. Talk to you.
>> M, can you step away from me, please?
>> Ma, can you step away from me, please?
>> I'm not in your personal space.
>> Thank you.
>> Step away from me, M.
>> Take my phone.
>> Please step away from me. You're going
to snatch my phone like he's going away.
He's actually going away.
>> You see how they're following? He's
following me.
>> You see this?
>> We're in a public space, bro.
>> We're in a public space.
>> So, if I feel like I got to defend
myself after moving around,
>> that's what it is.
>> What' you say, Emily?
>> This is what it is. Stop following me.
Please stop following me.
>> Please stop following me.
>> What are you going to do if I follow
you?
You lying. See, stop being annoying for
a minute. Just like back away. So,
>> if they come in my space, man, and I
feel like I got to defend myself for
being harassed.
>> Can you Can you show me what your space?
>> I will defend myself.
>> What is your space? Show me your space.
>> Is this your personal space?
>> I will defend myself
>> real quick.
>> I mean, why is he throwing at me?
Telling me that he's going to defend
myself. I mean, this is going to
escalate. I'm telling you. You guys are
going to walk away. It's going to
escalate. My name is M.
a little bit soon.
>> Look at them.
>> Dang. How long have we been live, guys?
>> How long How long have we been live?
>> You guys been with me from sun up so
down, man. [laughter]
and my daughter.
>> Okay, but it
>> all the way to Sunday cuz he's a he's
like a
>> he wants to be a streamer, you know? He
wants to be a famous person.
This is what it comes to.